what's going on everybody and welcome
back to the cosmic wonder where we talk
about things Marvel and MCU I'm your
host Warren Thompson and today we're
going to be talking about a interesting
topic we're going to be talking about
Black Panther 3. we're of course also
going to talk about Black Panther 2
wakanda forever however recently Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios
said some very interesting things in
terms of recasting t'challa and Black
Panther in an interview with Empire
magazine he explains what went through
everybody's Minds in terms of recasting
t'challa after Chadwick boseman's death
why they decided not to recast him but
it does appear that the folks over at
Marvel Studios could consider recasting
him for black panther 3. so even though
they didn't want to recast for black
panther 2 the option looks to still be
on the table for black panther 3 and
this kind of makes you wonder which
direction black panther 2 is actually
going to go there have been some pretty
crazy theories out there about what is
actually happening in the movie I've
heard some theories that state that
black panther wakanda forever simply
takes place during the snap and the
reason t'challa is dead is because he
got snapped away now of course we can
always argue that shuri was supposed to
be dead during that time because she
showed up on Avengers endgame on the
screen as far as the deceased Avengers
however they thought Scott Lang was dead
as well and he wasn't but we'll get into
that in just a bit let's first talk
about what Kevin feige said in the
Empire magazine interview also side note
Tina cuerta who of course is going to be
playing name or the Submariner in
wakanda Forever has confirmed also in an
interview with Empire magazine that his
character of course named where the
Submariner is indeed a mutant just like
he is in the comics so for those who
were worried myself included that Marvel
and Disney were going to make it to
where Neymar wasn't actually a mutant we
don't have to worry anymore he is
officially a mutant the Empire magazine
article reads according to Huerta his
name or is indeed a mutant now moving on
to the Empire article where Kevin feige
opened up to empire.com on the decision
to not recast t'challa Kevin feige said
in the article it just felt like it was
much too soon to recast he went on to
say Stan Lee always said that Marvel
represents the world outside your window
and we had talked about how as
extraordinary and Fantastical as our
characters and stories are there's a
relatable and human element to
everything we do the world is still
processing the loss of Chad and Ryan
poured that into the story now that
first one about Kevin feige stating that
he felt like it was too soon to recast
is extremely important but let's finish
this article and finish what Kevin feige
had to say about filming black panther
2. without Chadwick Boseman the article
continues and says once feige and Ryan
coogler figured out where they wanted to
go they got back to work on making a
sequel that really mattered Kevin feige
said the conversations were entirely
about yes what do we do next and how
could the Legacy of Chadwick and what he
had done to help wakanda and the Black
Panther become these incredible
aspirational iconic ideas continue
that's what it was all about so like
we've been hearing black panther 2
wakanda forever very much does honor
Chadwick Boseman but let's return to
that line that Kevin feige said in this
interview he said it just felt like it
was much too soon to recast this very
heavily implies that one day they might
actually recast t'challa or at the very
least recast a male black panther Kevin
feige just stated that the reason they
didn't recast him for black panther 2
was that it was too soon black panther 2
was coming out way too quickly after the
death of Chadwick Boseman this
essentially confirms that when Kevin
feige said that they have decided to not
recast t'challa he was simply stating
that they were not going to recast
t'challa for specifically black panther
2 because based off of what he just said
in this interview it sounds like if
enough time has passed fast and people
have had time to mourn they could start
to reconsider recasting now in another
interview again with Empire magazine we
do have a little bit of plot details
about Black Panther too but let's
quickly kind of talk about the end of
black panther 2 and then black panther 3
before diving into that because I
believe the ending of this black panther
film wakanda forever is going to leave
us with shuri as the Black Panther but
also the opportunity for another male to
be a black panther as well and that's
where I think black panther 3 is going
to be headed with a new black panther
the king of wakanda taking his place now
this may or may not be t'challa they
could simply recast a male black panther
and I continue to say male black panther
because shuri is definitely going to be
a black panther by the end of this movie
so I don't want to get the two of them
confused so it looks like at the end of
this film of course shuri will be the
Black Panther and then they're going to
set up a future black panther one that
we'll see in black panther 3. at that
point in time several years would have
gone by since Chadwick's death and
people would have had a little bit of
time to have mourned Chadwick's death
that way it's not insensitive to recast
and Chadwick would have got the respect
that he deserves and the rumors have
been going around by multiple insiders
that there indeed will be a new male
black panther by the end of black
panther 2. or it will at least set up
black panther 3 for that male black
panther to come in now as far as who
well there have been a few different
rumors going out there none of which we
can actually confirm to be true of
course but one of which is that imbaku
will take on the mantle and become Black
Panther and the king of wakanda another
is that t'challa and Nakia actually had
a kid off-screen and that child will
grow up and of course become the
rightful king of wakanda and the next
Black Panther there are quite honestly a
few different options but the main point
of this is Kevin feige has stated that
the reason they didn't recast before
because it was too soon so when enough
time goes by we could be getting a new
black panther again a male black panther
because Sherry will be Black Panther in
this film now like I mentioned this
magazine article did reveal some plot
details about Black Panther wakanda
forever that have basically confirmed my
suspicions on what this movie is
actually about this interview was with
Tina cuerta Neymar himself and he was
talking about how it's not going to be
Atlantis in the movie like it is in the
comics but this Incarnation is going to
be inspired by the culture and history
of mesoamerica and here's what he says
about it that actually gives us some
plot details he says you can take
Atlantis from Greek myth or you can
adapt from a real culture rather than
the ruler of Atlantis on the screen he's
the ruler of taliken and he's drawn to
the surface by the ramifications of
t'challa's decision in Black Panther's
final reel to reveal the truth of
wakanda to the world and then he says
that decision puts talukan in Jeopardy
and telecan has to take action to
protect themselves so this basically
confirms why Neymar and talukan are at
war with wakanda much like a lot of us
have assumed it is because because of
vibranium black panther told the entire
world about vibranium and now the world
and some evil people in the world want
it so what are they doing they're
searching for it and where are they
searching for it off the coast of
wakanda and of course where does Namor
and taliken reside off the coast of
wakanda so it's pretty easy to see why
Namor is really upset with wakanda and
the actions of t'challa t'challa and
wakanda basically put the entire nation
of telecon in Jeopardy whether it's they
don't want the world to find out about
them underwater or they're afraid that
their people could get hurt or it could
be the fact that talukan probably has
some vibranium that they keep for
themselves as well and they don't want
the vibranium that they have to fall
into the arms of somebody bad now we
know from the footage that was shown at
San Diego Comic-Con and then at d23 that
a group of soldiers board a ship and the
ship appears to be a wakandan ship they
are in search for vibranium but the Dora
milaje are undercover there and they
defeat them now we don't know who these
soldiers are they could be working for
some government or they could just
simply be hired by somebody maybe even
Dr Doom because there is a rumor going
around that Doom is behind everything
but we'll have to wait and see on that
that is not confirmed however that is a
story do more from the comics so perhaps
Doom is trying to get Namor and the
atlanteans or the taconians to try and
attack wakanda and destroy it so he can
then come in and take the vibranium but
either way we now know what the
disruption is between Namor and his
people and the wakandans Namor is mad
that wakanda told the world about
vibranium because now people are trying
to get it and are most likely disturbing
and attacking his people so I'm assuming
that Namor is going to tell wakanda hey
cut off everything with you and the rest
of the world tell everybody to stay back
don't let anybody into wakanda tell
everybody they can't have vibranium
however one of the last things that
t'challa did when he was alive was open
up the world to the help of wakanda so
they probably don't want to undo what
t'challa did but we'll have to see how
how this all plays out it looks like
wakanda forever is going to be an
amazing movie and it looks like it is
going to set up black panther 3 to have
a new Black Panther and depending on
when this movie actually does take place
we could even get a new t'challa I'm not
counting on that but it is possible but
let me know your thoughts on this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos for
live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
baby